for a homeless population to grow at the
rate that it is growing
those people weren't homeless some of
them were but yes
many of these people have gone from
having the ability to house themselves
to not having it
and what you know we have allowed that
to happen
um well again i mean not to
want to play the sort of conservative
card too much back at you but um
one thing that i've accessible in
everyone's mind is is there a scenario
that you can imagine in which the person
does actually deserve to be on the
streets
no no this is a problem isn't it it's
the same thing
as the portions of the left i'm not
saying you find it very hard to see what
scenario leads anyone to be in prison
well and it's something on the same
trajectory of thought
which is that i i don't think that
homelessness per se can ever be stopped
because i think that for instance
there will be some people who
actually i mean again it's impossible to
tell exactly what fortune there will be
a portion of people who want that
i've noticed that in san francisco and
elsewhere i mean there are some people
who seem to
want to live on the streets there's
there's a very it's a
small proportion perhaps but a voluntary
street dwelling population might might
be something you you can't eradicate
what you want to eradicate is the people
who fell through
through through layer after layer after
layer of the society and absolutely do
not want to be there
but as with um as with prison as with
other things in our society where an
individual ends up in a catastrophic
situation
there does have to be some understanding
of
not not always assuming that it was
society that caused the thing to happen
because i mean this is let me give an
example of an example
it's obvious in american society there's
a debate over incarceration
that has been going along for a long
time in incarceration rates particularly
over
uh in breaking down by racial origin
and one of the answers that people have
come to on this i think actually it's a
pretty good place to contest
um is is over incarceration rates of
black
particularly male americans over
relatively low level drug
issues um dealing in small amounts of
marijuana what do you do
large amounts of marijuana and all of
the comparisons and me
this is this is what we were going back
to earlier
about the distribution of opportunity
much more in society which is that
that is it's a good place to contest
this um it does seem unfair to people
and i think and i would share this
that that somebody whatever the racial
origin
has their entire life affected
disenfranchised future job opportunities
forever
taken from them for what could be seen
as a relatively minor offense
and people leaning on this seem to me to
be leaning on something which is
it is reasonable it's a reasonable
concern the problem is
that those same people will not allow
themselves to say
what is the thing that means yes you
should be banged up
you should have future opportunities
taken away from you because what you've
done is
deeply harmful to everyone else in
society and the problem is is these
people
they say mainly a leftist problem cannot
do that bit
yeah and and that's the same thing with
it
and this is you know the the right can
be heartless
uh uh uh at times but there are times
where a form of heartlessness is
necessary
if somebody is determined to do a thing
and does it again and again you cannot
then say that
we as a society let them down no
that person is responsible they have to
pay yeah oh i totally agree
question you asked me was whether
anybody deserves to be homeless
right do people deserve to be in prison
many do
um the so i'm not sure by the way i'm
not sure that i think anyone deserves to
be homeless
right but i'm saying the situation that
emerges that means that having some
people
will screw up again and again and again
and some people
we present it only in terms of they
haven't got the help they need
yeah that is a very reasonable way to
present it
but as you know we all know there are
people who every single
opportunity you give them they
they fall through well okay you've got
two categories i'd say there are three
categories right
you've got a category of people who
given enough
functional structure would
be productive and decent and have fallen
through the cracks because there's no
safety net right then you have people
who
meet your description who given every
opportunity
can't pull it together but not
necessarily because
they want it that way they may be badly
damaged and just incapable of
uh you know doing the kinds of things
that would that would solve the problem
and then you've got a undoubtedly a
category of people and i don't know how
big it is but a category of people
who just suck and aren't interested in
participating in society
and you know i would argue
homelessness is not a right answer in
any of those three categories
in part not just because of the people
involved the first two categories i
would argue
deserve our compassion right the third
category i don't know that they deserve
our compassion
but is it good for society to have
homeless people
it is not and so you have to provide
some
reasonable alternative but you also have
to make sure that that third category
whatever
number they are do not end up confusing
and confounding the rest of society
so 100 this is
it well you know it's a parent's dilemma
again it's it's it's that
at some point
it cannot be extrapolated out onto
everybody else when one person has
behaved in a certain way for which they
have to pay
total and with respect to the prison
side of the equation
i would say i think it is insane that we
do not distinguish
between um at the very least
sociopaths and maybe i mean psychopaths
in this case
and other criminals right and and so
it's
because the criminal one is in some ways
easier but i mean
going back to this thing there's
protests in portland the other night
because of
i gather sparked by the fact that a
family
who happened to be black um stopped
paying their rent some time ago
the landlord wants to um evict them
because
they haven't been paying their rent and
they say racism
and now people are campaigning for this
family to stay in
in the home the family itself says that
when you say they they say so yes as i
understand it
the the people who live in the house say
it yeah because of racism
i would venture as an outsider adventure
it's highly unlikely that
racism is the cause of the landlord
wanting to evict them and that it's more
likely that the landlord wants to be
paid for
right leasing his house to a to anybody
whatever their skin color i don't know
maybe we found a white supremacist
landlord in portland it's a
strange place for white supremacists to
try to earn their keep but whatever
um but but in this situation
every mechanism of the site and this
isn't just important every mechanism
of the society is in favor of the family
who is not paying the rent right very
very little and i'm not going to say
paul's an extreme example
but in general outside very little of
society looks to the
landlord who is losing money and thinks
that we should pity
them and that's because our societal
ethic
again it starts in a good place it just
doesn't know where the hell to stop
favors the person who appears to be the
underdog over the person who
is perceived to have privilege and we
have become wildly
intolerant of and unsympathetic with
anybody perceived to have privilege
and wildly oversympathetic with anybody
who can be claimed to be in any way an
oppressed group even if
they are allegedly oppressed because
there's something they haven't been
doing
which they should have done that was the
deal right
well so in this case i would just say um
a if you extrapolate and this is the
thing i think
in some sense americans are worst at at
the moment is extrapolating
but if you extrapolate from well we
can't very well evict these people for
not paying
because it doesn't matter what follows
the because once you set
that in motion the point is what you've
done is
invalidated a system that houses people
without suggesting a replacement for it
so it's insane right it's just simply
unstable
that thing of people falling off the
bottom when i said earlier you know
should any does anyone deserve to be
homeless what i'm trying to get at is
um society cannot
rack itself endlessly over the tiny
number of people
who actually fall through their own
volition right
okay we cannot be endlessly empathetic
with those who have been given every
opportunity and
still fall and one of the reasons is and
i mean this is a very again it's a very
ugly very unpleasant thing to say
perhaps is
that knowing that that is possible is
one of the things that keeps everyone
else
running well so
see citing that i mean i have this
instinct always with the
homeless like i'm by no means heartless
on this issue but
you know you i you know it depends
what your state in life is but i've
certainly had times in my life where i
see somebody who's begging and i think
could be me could be me and that's a
good instinct to have for lots of
reasons one is it gives you sympathy
with the person in question
and the other thing is it reminds you to
[Music]
work
[Music]
you